well my memories good hello everyone I'm
Ricky Dillon I'm a youtuber my channel
is Ricky Dillon and I've been on YouTube
for a long time now it's been nine years
but I've been like serious about it for
like seven ish this is my glamorous
amazing setup I know don't be too
excited I'm definitely not like a
cameraman
I hate like setting up stuff I do like
the simplest stuff about 2090 awsome
tane when i first started it was
definitely slow for the first couple of
years I I didn't do it to like get big
or make money I didn't make money for
like four years probably on YouTube at
that point it wasn't like my job I was
still I was finishing high school and I
was in college I enjoyed that
crazy video I actually was a late for an
internship in the summer for college and
then I was opposed to go back and finish
my senior year after that summer the
timing was great because that's when my
channel was like really kicking off and
I was in a group called o2l or Second
Life it was a collab channel on YouTube
there was six of us we each had a day of
the week I was Tuesday and we actually
wanted Teen Choice Award
whoo but told my parents I was like
don't be mad but I want to give this a
shot so I want to drop out of college
things go wrong I'll go back to college
obviously but I gave it a shot and it
just worked out from there here's my
trumpet my next video is actually gonna
be me covering ariana grande songs on
trumpet I got it so there's several ways
to make money as a youtuber the most
like common way that every youtuber it
makes money is the ads by videos it's
called like revenue when you watch a
video you'll see like a pre-roll ad or
ad on the side whoever's channel that is
they make money because of that ad so
that's like the normal like bass basic
way that everyone can do but there's
also things called like brand deals or
like sponsorships where you can like
tour get the brand directly and you give
them like a shout out in a video and you
get like paid for that but also there's
like merch I've released music I get
music sales I've gone on tour before
I've released a book so there's a lot of
things you can do the company can all
stem from like your channel but the
basic like normal thing is like monthly
like revenues mess
where she Luna hey come here she's a
good girl wait for this amazing crunch
she's best so YouTube is obviously
really fun I love it would it change it
for the world but it definitely is very
challenging for many reasons one its
unpredictable when you have like a
normal desk job and you you you clock in
and clock out you know what you're doing
you have like a set salary with YouTube
nothing is like predictable it's all
like random and it can change anytime so
there's a lot of like anxiety and stress
it comes with it which I've been dealing
with a lot there's low points all the
time I mean like I've dealt with that
this year like I said YouTube mr. di
rollercoaster so the high points are
obviously amazing but the low points
they really suck and I used to like get
horrible anxiety over it to the point
where like I would like shut down for
like a few days and I still do with that
sometimes but I am better about like
hailing it cuz I have done it for salt
for so long I've seen the ups and downs
I know things will always work out I
have like 30 costumes I have tons of
wigs I have like stuff ready for like I
need to dress up for videos should I get
some my wigs this is my are gonna Grande
Wagar here it's a silly one I love doing
like comedy sketches where I'm like
playing like purposely like silly
characters it's just fun to like look
bad on purpose it's definitely hard to
become successful because it's you can't
just like say you want to do it have it
happen and back when I did it it was a
lot easier because there was like
contests and like you can like audition
for like collab channels I feel like the
best way now is to follow a trend always
make it your own don't like copy someone
make it me do have your own take on it
but it's hard like even like even now
that I have gotten like my success it
can be hard still to do well at times
because there's just so much on YouTube
now it's like a lot right here we have
this amazing tepee tent thingy with
dolls inside you're probably wondering
what this is from I did a video where I
basically like I clicked every ad I saw
and bought whatever the ad was
and the first ad was this doll and so I
guess the internet like learns when you
click an ad what you like so every ad
from that point on was like doll stuff
you have to do it because you really
liked it a lot of people I think it's
like these days more recently they do it
to make money or to be famous and people
see right through that you have to do
because you truly love to do it and you
got to be consistent and like stay with
it very very rarely will someone blow up
right away overnight like that's very
rare so you have to like stay with it be
consistent
do your best to upload frequently but
enjoy it if you really try for I feel
like anybody can get a following if
you're passionate about it and have a
good content base anybody won't get a
following eventually like good stuff
find its way people talk about it they
share it so I think if you're consistent
enough and really really want it you'll
get there and the other day I love
YouTube I love just making stuff I love
entertaining I love like editing I love
creating anything so the joy of youtube
is that my job and career is what I love
to do I mean like I said I started
YouTube before I even know you could you
can make money so the fact that like my
career now is what I truly love doing
it's just awesome so I love just like
getting an idea out of nowhere like
making it and like editing and putting
together interesting responses I love
filming with like my friends as well I
do a lot of collabs so it's just fun and
it's cool that I can like call my job my
hobby as well
[Music]